really just days ago like i think two
weeks ago
i was diagnosed with cancer kathy
griffin reveals
she's battling lung cancer the
60-year-old comedian took to social
media on monday to share that she's been
diagnosed with stage one of the disease
kathy shared a note on instagram shortly
before going into surgery to have quote
half of my left lung removed she wrote
yes i have lung cancer even though i've
never smoked
the doctors are very optimistic as it is
stage one and contained to my left lung
kathy says she's hopeful that she won't
require chemotherapy or radiation after
the surgery
adding quote i should have normal
function with my breathing
and adds that her recovery time would be
a month or less
the comedian also shares quote it's been
a hell of a four years
trying to get back to work making you
guys laugh and entertaining you
but i'm gonna be just fine i was
definitely in shock i'm still a little
bit in shock not denial
kathy is also speaking about her
diagnosis on nightline
a friend of mine said how many kicks in
the nuts can you take and i'm like my
nuts are pretty strong but
it's a challenge in a sneak peek clip
the former reality star opens up about
the hardships she has faced over the
past few years
here you are you want the clean break
yeah you're
you're finally dusting yourself off and
beginning to jog
and it feels like you get knocked down
again i still like
once a day i'll just turn to like nobody
next to me and go can you believe this
is this a [ __ ] or what back in march of
2020
kathy's mother maggie griffin passed
away at the age of 99 after suffering
from
dementia that same month kathy also had
a scary stay in the coven 19 emergency
ward
she also faced backlash in 2017 after
sharing a disturbing photo holding a
ketchup covered halloween mask
resembling then president donald trump
in 2019 the comedian opened up to e.t
about what it was like moving past that
scandal
it's been an interesting journey to see
that i definitely lost
a group of fans that will probably never
come back but i gained a lot of sort of
resistors and people that are a little
more in tune with what's going on in the
landscape
and i i sort of became a little bit more
of a political comedian because
of this but i don't know if that's going
to be forever though kathy has been
through a lot
she also shared what she would like to
accomplish moving forward
i would like to do something probably on
television or in the
streaming space that number one
once again reminds people it's it's
kathy griffin that you've known for
years
you know uh making you laugh premier
obviously primarily as a comedian
and it would be nice to do something
where
more americans could kind of get back to
that place